it is uh my 52nd birthday and uh the
crew here has
arranged for not one not two but three
mystery guests to call in
and the first one is already called in
right here on this day
uh mystery guest how are you
oh no it was a good pause because i knew
you guys would get
to where you were how are you my brother
what's up michael irvin
how are you irv i i rich happy birthday
my brother
happy birthday and i call you my brother
and i mean that not with that color
thing that we call each other brothers
with
but a blood soul brothers and i
appreciate you brother happy birthday
thank you michael irvin i i do love you
uh intensely we bring this up frequently
um but you were at my wedding um by the
way 18 years ago
earlier this month you were there uh
because susie invited you because you
and she
uh had worked together on fox sports
back in the day so i've known you
forever
and a day as a friend and and um a loved
one
for sure yes rich absolutely buddy i'm
so glad as i
as i text to you and i will share this
with everybody i'm so glad
that god intertwined our our lives the
way he has and we've gone
back so long and and going forward so
much farther ahead so i so i just
appreciate that buddy and i love your
family matt
and uh and you do a great job and you do
a great job with
us every sunday as we come into
everybody's homes
man i'm just so blessed to have you
happy birthday
i do feel the same way about you i do
feel the same way about you or what have
you been up to
let's talk let's kick it well i'm up to
everything
oh my god these these playhouse
chris it's been insane it
they've been crazy rich if it's so good
it's been so good
now i mean did anybody expect them to be
this good
without lebron and without steph curry i
mean
like they are right now i don't know
that many people thought it would be
this good what'd you think of uh
trey young shimmy last night irv what'd
you think of that one
before he charged when he just kind of
shimmed it right there the three before
he
took that shot like yeah
and your boy over in the huddle say
we're just going to let him do this
right in our building over here when
janice was saying that
i thought that and let me tell you
something that kid understands how big
this moment is
he understands it he's been waiting on
this
his whole life his whole
life you know those free throws
i tweeted this kid ain't gonna miss the
free throws he's
he shot that free throw so many times
in his own head before he got right
there
in the reality he wasn't going to miss
the free throws i i just love seeing his
gross move
and and that rpo he has on the
basketball court rich
that's the rpo you know what i mean
that's that run
that that's that run pass option you
have on the football field that little
teardrop
you don't know if it's a shot or whoop
oh
yeah they deadly with that irv and and
uh
you know the the power of belief i think
that's what we're seeing too
i think that's why you're into this
because i know you i know you
and and the power of belief
is so uh intense when you see it
manifest in a playoff series regardless
of the sport we talk about it all the
time with the nfl
and just seeing these four teams
sons clippers sons the last couple of
games without chris paul looks like he's
coming back tonight
and clippers without kawhi dispatching
with the one seed jazz
winning four in a row the last two
without kawhi the bucks
you know doing what they did against the
nets who almost did it
without kyrie and then of course the
hawks i think maybe that's what you're
into at the nba playoffs right now
fight against and rich you hit the nail
on the head in this sense
because all of these guys these young
teams you know with deception of the
bucks
uh these are young teams stepping out
trying to grab their piece of the pot
i i i grabbed michael wilbon and i had
him on
my podcast michael urban podcast yes i
have michael
and we talked about this we talked about
it and he said even at atlanta team he
picked out atlanta you know
i see it in in in phoenix and also
he talked about how they look like we
looked
early on when we went into san francisco
and nobody really thought we would beat
san francisco they thought we were a
year away
we were a young teen rich that believed
just like you're talking about
and we believe more than everybody else
and that thing can carry you man
and that's what you're seeing and and
quite a few of these young teams right
now that's why i love it you're right
that's what i'm drawn to
yeah because and that's that's what um
i think many who are or into this are
are drawn to
as well you know because and that's what
we need right now
this is what what we're getting what we
need
even though we may not know we need it
coming off of what we just came up with
all of this covet right now we need this
so our bodies it's like it is it's like
your body
our body's craving it and we're getting
it that's why the ratings are up
what 39 to 40 percent over last year
right now
in these nba playoffs because we need
this we've been craving this
and by golly we get it yeah we are
getting i mean
cameron payne with 29 in game two
against the clippers just kevin herder
doing what he did in game seven for the
hawks
um you know heroes chris middleton
exactly
christmas stadium oh my god
and man that game players man their man
head over there
exactly terence man against against the
jazz
and and you're we're watching what trey
young's doing what was that
so let me get into this with you michael
irvin when you were in your
um your playoff run your playoff heyday
your playoff ascension
wha what what were you thinking about as
that kid
from fort lauderdale from saint thomas
aquinas
uh you know one of many in your
household with many brothers and sisters
getting that shot knowing that this is
your opportunity that you had been
building for your entire life
what was that mindset for you earth to
go and going for that stage
and go for the stage and and anything
about now and it is
you know you get a little bite and
there's you get a little bite of it that
you want more you want more because we
went through that process remember first
year we go
we go beat chicago i'm like oh my god oh
they go to detroit and get slaughtered
right you know what i'm saying
we're going to slaughter but he was like
okay
next year we get back here this won't
happen again
you know you know what i'm saying and it
changes things rich it's nothing
like it man to walk on that floor right
there
you saw when through young held up at
one right after
it goes back to what you were talking
about and the other dude
they've won on the road in every series
and they believe they can win on the
road we don't get one we don't get what
we've got one
that that that right there man that
connects it's the same thing i was
telling you guys
tampa had when we were watching the
super bowl
when i was saying no no no no this can't
happen i'm telling y'all why champ is
going to win this game
right it's that thing man it's just a
beautiful thing to watch it really is
michael irvin here on the richison show
wherever i noticed on your instagram
account at michael irvin88
uh you attended a mavs clippers game uh
with zeke and dak and uh there's a
photograph up on the screen right there
um two things leave to mind first thing
first um
what was with the pants you're wearing i
mean there were holes all over it
i mean i know that uh we're trying to
maintain a youthful appearance but
what was that or what are those pants
right there
some genes rich you know the first thing
is my favorite first the first comment
made when i walked in was man but you
get those jeans i i need to get a pair
of those
who said that what i'm saying who said
that that's the first thing he said well
well
i wouldn't call them jeans i'd call them
gene there's only there's a lot missing
you know i mean
they were covered they were covering
patches you know what i mean they have
covered you know
it was skin shown i i came to a 55 year
old man
[Laughter]
okay but so so zeke says i gotta get me
uh
some of those what was uh well how was
dak what was that like
you're taking the temperature of two of
the three current triplets
what do you got what was that all about
oh yeah man hey listen man
and they're they're in this great
spirits i mean jackets you know zach is
back
he really is back man i love that he's
declared
hey that's behind me because he knows he
knows
he's got to go through stages it really
does
you know when you come back from an
injury like that you have to go through
stages like okay i'm on the trail so
pretty good
all right people around me now okay i i
can still move out i can jump out and
get out quick
quicker now now he still hasn't gone
through that stage and really having
live bullets alive bodies flying around
him
so so so he knows he has to fight that
ultimate monster right there
but it's a fight that i know dad could
be ready for when he meets it on the
football field
in his mind he'll be ready for it and
when he gets over that rich
it'll be over it will be over over what
what do you mean over
what's the phrase over in reference to
why because i i i believe
that dak is one of those guys that that
that loves
to to uh
over uh uh or over over uh over deliver
yes
over deliver you you didn't no one gave
him a chance when he was coming in
no question he's done hey he over
delivered nobody gave chance to win the
job he
he over delivers those first say what
you will about what you're paying him
now
for what you paid him before he over
delivered
and now you're paying him a lot and i do
believe he'll still
over deliver now that means delivering
something great
when you get paid 42 45 million dollars
a year
yes and that challenge he does a great
job of attacking
meeting and beating every time
so um by the way i believe in him in
immensely i love the guy you're right he
has over delivered
we we did not expect him to do what he
did when romo's back broke in a
preseason game in seattle didn't expect
that didn't see that one coming
didn't see romo in the cbs booth
essentially coming right
because because dak was so terrific and
then last year what he was needing he
had to over deliver and he was doing
that i get it
what does over deliver look like this
year
wow yeah you come back and just deliver
what he was delivering yesterday
yesterday yes sir yesteryear bef
pri prior to the injury
if you come back and deliver that
because he was
he was he was phenomenal yes he was
phenomenal
and and the defense tightens down and it
will tighten down
and and with that another year even
though
yeah he went through what he went
through but you know another year uh uh
wiser now with understanding thing and
then understanding what you're doing
what control of it
then i get yeah you'll see and i and i
say over deliver
means you can run into the playoffs and
get deep now i just talked to you about
how biting those things off have to come
through a process do i believe there's a
chance that they can bite
all the way to a super bowl absolutely
absolutely
but it will come with the process as
they get into the playoffs and get
deeper
into a playoff and i want to see them
get to that
where they're ready to go deeper into a
playoffs all the time
rich and then sometimes we'll be able to
bite off the super bowl well irv one of
the many reasons why i love you
uh is multifaceted one that you're you
you would answer the call like hey
call in and wish rich a happy birthday
you'll surprise him
uh and and another one is that that uh
um
i know professionally you are ready for
anything you're ready for a curveball to
be snapped off 12-6
you know midnight to 6 p.m you're ready
for that and
uh i'm about to throw one your way right
now as a birthday wish to me
and and this is also front loading what
what andy greg and richard isico and the
rest of the nfl game day morning
production staff is going to throw at
you anyway so this is kind of front
loading it
i've got the dallas cowboys schedule
here i want to go win loss one by one
with you
and figure out what the schedule will
actually give me in terms of
wins loss by the end of the year the
record okay michael irvin
happy birthday to me
come on come on give him the nfl films
music here we go
right now right now on june on correct
on june on june
24th oh my birthday this is you know i
haven't even seen
i just told you about the step in which
that no that's too
that's true that's two amorphous that's
too amorphous i need to actually peg a
win and a loss to schedules right now
we won't hold you to it we'll burn the
tape we'll burn the tape
and by the way and by the way earth this
is my gift to you
this is no 100 seconds this is my gift
to you because if you're right
you will definitely use this this could
be usable so it's disposable if you're
wrong until i bring it up again
but if you're right if you're right
imagine how great you'll be you're a
seer you want to be a seer you talk
about you're a seer all the time
correct brockman you've heard that i'm a
seer speech
on the set of game day morning before on
the air you've heard it on here correct
chris
absolutely i got your faith in the
legend rich i got faith in the legend
okay
here we go the playmaker i can go
through this i can go through it yes
yeah here we go happy birthday to me all
right michael irvin
opener at tampa cowboys win loss what do
you got for me win loss
oh the size of this game
what do you got for me what do you got
his size
is huge
um can you win a super bowl at home and
then turn around and lose an opener
at home facing america's team yeah
oh we gotta
win loss do the right thing earlier it's
his first game back
that gets a great here it he has agreed
gets his fill back for the game in this
game
but but they make they'll come out of
this one with the l even though doc will
play great all right
okay very good irv you dressed it up
very nicely but it lost is a loss
on one what do you got next at at the
chargers
get it you start kicking the tires on
the building where you might play the
super bowl what do you got
at the chargers okay
monday night at home against the
philadelphia eagles what do you got
come on they'll beat the eagles okay
all right sam darnold coming in the same
sam darnold that
sliced up the cowboys a couple years ago
when you and i were at dinner in london
what do you got this workshop great it's
working what are you talking about
this works out crazy all right that's it
right now they're sitting three and one
three and one right now and then you
lose opener but right now you're sitting
three and one coming out of that first
quarter
even though he's quartered with one
extra quarter that's right yeah seven
that's true
it's quarter-ish with 17 regular season
games home for the giants
home for the giants you you're
home for the giants that you go in you
beat that game you win that game that's
four and one oh yeah at belichick and
the patriots
week six oh my god oh my god
and this this you gotta get rid of that
gnaring
taste in your mouth from what happened
even even in that storm and i know right
now gilmore is wanting some more money
but but if i'm amari and all of them i
want to go see them again
so yes you get a cowboy a win right here
that's a five-game win streak
yes that's five and one going to the bye
and you are you are showing up at week
seven nfl game day morning we are having
a blast and you're like you got nothing
like
normally that's when we start hammering
you that's normally when we got the
what's wrong with the cowboys topic bar
you will be just high stepping into that
bye week
and then you come out of bye week you go
visit when they're five and one we're
going to the bye week bridge i'm wearing
a 14
karat gold suit
okay at the vikings coming out of the
fire on halloween at the vikings
trick or treat with kirk cousins what do
you got
oh that's that it'll be a close game
because mike oh yeah
do a great job with defense but i do
believe the cowboys win that
sunday night sunday night football
that's a six game win streak
home for the broncos oh come on man
oh my god the cowboys win that game
home for the falcons home for the
falcons
you beat the falcons that's an
eight-game
streak they lose the opener and then
eight oh my god
then they're at the kansas city chiefs
[Music]
okay and this is going to be your
message here now because right now
this is this is like one of those play
games that we're talking about where you
have to bite off and they'll become a
big man here
they did the chiefs sweet just squeaked
by
they squeaked by and they went with the
late field goal
get this buy one later go
buy one okay so the eight game win
streak gets butt kickered is what you're
saying so
now it's uh right right right but get
what it does now get what it does get
what it does
this hurts but prepares
in the midst of this great thing for
your great promise it forges
it forges and you remember it when you
see them again go ahead
i got that it forges it forges then
comes thanksgiving with the mayox the
raiders in
oh come on man okay that's nine and two
you got you beat raiders at the saints
the next
next thursday full week of rest for both
teams because the saints play on
thanksgiving two at the saints
this is going to be a tough game because
it's at the saints yes the cowboys
right now what are their record where
the cowboys record 92 82
992 992 the saints oh my god
and remember we have people back in the
building now that's right yeah back in
the building oh yeah and i've said
many times on the show rich the only
place
that made my bones shiver inside my body
is when i played inside that super dome
cowboys lose this game all right that's
nine and
nine and three at the washington
football team here we go we're gonna
finish
up strong what do you got fitzy
yeah it's probably gonna be fitzpatrick
getting his job back
because magic he's going he's going to
get you
one time in the year he's going to get
you there's no doubt
he's going to do that back-to-back
losses
cowboys right there okay he's got it
nine and four at the giants you sweep
the giants you sweep the dice
all right all right 10 and four let's
finish up strong home for the washington
football team
day after christmas on nbc sunday night
and this is where you deliver your
revenge
home for the cardinals who came in and
gave you the spank-a-lanka
last year to use your phrase yeah you
beat the cardinals now you got a better
defense than you or
you could if you contain everything and
kyla murray
uh yeah okay and then uh
finish up at the philadelphia eagles you
sweep the eagles
well here by right now we're running
into an issue
of feeding right now so so so now
it gets to be uh does it matter you're
saying will it matter when the 12 and 4
go into week 17
that's what you're saying will they rest
their starters that's what you're saying
right
right that's what we're talking about or
maybe you get the win
you get the win when siriani benches
jalen hurts to see what he's got in
flacco
in the fourth quarter what do you think
the final game of the year wait where's
this game is this game home
it's in philly in philly cold day on
january 9th
yeah yeah yeah yeah is that a loss you
see saying you're going to class
rich it's a hard one it goes on what's
around
if the cowboys are needing it for for
the race of of trying to get home field
uh a better seating then then they win
that football game
but if they do not then they're going to
sit people at rest
come on this is mr lock of the week give
me a give me something
to say but but i will say they're
looking to try to get
uh uh top seed and they win that
football game also
michael irvin michael irvin doing the
dallas cowboys win-loss game says the
2021 dallas cowboys as of june 24th
my 52nd birthday on this planet in 2021
says the cowboys in 2021 will go 13 and
4. this takes a nice chunk out of the
pie there you go
whoa
what they have that is absolutely that
that
that is that that that that's that's
great analogy
the three eyes in michael irvin come out
at the end
right that way when these things break
that way like i'm telling you
that's what i'm for what they have they
can do that i love you michael irvin
thanks for calling in you're the best
i'll see you soon probably in canton
that's the next time i'll see you but
have a great day
to work i put you to work
but i front loaded it you're gonna be
asked to do this you know you're gonna
be put in front of a touch screen
you know first chance the producers get
to make you do what i just did
with you this is right we're gonna be
looking forward to richard i
i tell you what this will be one of the
most anticipated and i really do believe
and if i see
we've had a
take care of yourself have a great
fourth we'll chat soon love you brother
okay buddy i love you too happy birthday
thank you man thank you michael irvin
everybody
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here